protests in South Africa happen a lot
sometimes every day low wages Rising
poverty the High Cost of Living and
Corruption are some of the issues raised
by workers
the country's biggest Trade union group
kosatu feels a governing African
National Congress at times excludes it
from crucial decision-making processes
we hope that we will begin as we started
to reconfigure the alliance because
that's a call of courseato we want to
reconfigure the alliance reconfiguring
the alliance means that any program that
the ANC government is going to have it
must have a support of the alliance
because I do Communist Party the ANC has
governed South Africa since white
minority rule ended in 1994 but it
hasn't been easy unions have a lot of
bargaining power here the governing
African National Congress is part of an
alliance along with the Congress of
South African trade unions and the South
African Communist party and the ANC
needs their votes and can't afford to
ignore them
differences about who and how South
Africa should be run has seen some
unions threatened to pull out of the
alliance with the ANC and form their own
political party those differences have
always been there and we've always been
able to resolve those differences it's
not the first time that some within
cosatu might have felt that they would
want to leave the alliance who
consistently engaged and we found Common
Ground some in the Communist Party had
also felt that don't want to contest
elections alone as the party those
contradictions are there but
consistently we do an engage
president Sarah ramaphosa sees his
administration is working on turning
around the economy create more jobs and
deal with those implicated incorruption
elections are next year analysts say if
a split were to ever happen between
trade unions and South Africa's
governing party that could hurt the
anc's chances of holding on to its
majority
Al Jazeera Johannesburg